scp-035 vs scp-999  who would win this incredibly malicious  mask or the incredibly kind and lovable  tickle monster let's find out  scp-035 is an undeniably powerful foe  from its caustic black liquid to the  incredibly compelling mental energy that  it unleashes to convince its unwitting  victims to put it on but what would this  power do against scp-999  being a living blob it doesn't have a  fixed face in the traditional sense as a  result it may be difficult for 035 to  bond with 999 and thus take it over we  also believe it's equally possible that  the powerful good vibes of 999 could  counteract the mental control of scp-035  and if it can truly reverse this  polarity perhaps the nasty mask would  chill out for once